12 people are dead eight are wounded
four in critical condition as terrorists
opened fire in the offices of the french
satirical newspaper charlie at doe this
all took place in paris around 1130am
paris time the gunman the three gunmen
are still at large world leaders have
expressed their sympathy and
condemnation of the attacks Prime
Minister David Cameron of Britain had
this to say in Parliament this morning I
know that this house and this country
stands United with the French people in
our opposition to all forms of terrorism
and we stand squarely for free speech
and democracy and these people will
never be able to take us off those
values British Prime Minister David
Cameron he along with that German
Chancellor Angela Merkel are set to
holds a news conference later in the
hour which we will cover live it is
taking place at 10 Downing Street to
discuss the future of the European Union
and of course today's attack for more
let's bring in Bloomberg's on Ryan
Chilcote he is standing by outside of 10
Downing Street Ryan how does today's
attack change the dialogue between Prime
Minister David Cameron and Angela Merkel
well it changes it completely the
official reason the German Chancellor is
in London today is because she was
wanted to discuss the g7 and her agenda
for the g7 Germany's hosting the big g7
summit the Bavarian Alps in June and she
wanted to discuss it with the British
Prime Minister then this happened both
leaders of course condemning the events
in France both saying that it was
barbaric I say the official reason for
the German Chancellor's visit was to
discuss the g7 but what the British
Prime Minister really wanted to talk
about is this country's relationship
with the European Union and his desire
to curb immigration of EU migrants
coming into this country there's no
direct link of course between the events
in in France today but there is a bit of
an indirect one if you will it certainly
puts a little bit of a charge to the
political conversation about immigration
in this country pin and Ryan this is
brendan both of these leaders on
lemarchal and David Cameron have
domestic politics of their own to worry
about that are very much informed by
what happened in Paris this morning you
have the UK Independence Party
which is dragging david cameron to the
right and angle america was dealing with
protests anti-immigrant protests in her
own country so both of them are looking
to home as well right yeah that's
exactly right and I think there's a
little bit of a difference if you think
about you Kip that you're referring to
there the leader of that party just in
the last couple of weeks has said that
they're not a racist movement in fact he
said that if they were a racist but
they're perceived that way that would be
the end of their existence and rise
because they really have been on the
rise here in this country they describe
themselves as an anti EU party they are
against immigration wherever that comes
from not necessarily Islamic but in
Germany it is very much an anti Islamist
movement that is taking place there and
we see those demonstrations just
yesterday the German Chancellor spoke
against the anti Islamist movement in
her New Year's address to the German
people so yeah it's very much informing
their thoughts on in the the discussions
today